[Music]
what up this is you welcome with Marcel
Arguello [ __ ] that's me
and we have a great show today we have
two wonderful comedians Katie McVeigh
stand-up comedian and she has a great
series on YouTube called yell you better
and race ani another amazing comedian
and a writer as well she's written on
the good plays and on black lady's
sketch show coming up on HBO so check
all these projects out we got some
talented [ __ ] up in here how are you
ladies doing good yeah great good to be
here
yeah I'm excited to have you yeah you a
high as [ __ ] I'm straight no I don't
care
I want you to be high as [ __ ] I want
should be too should've been regrets so
Katy and I met when we were working at
Bill Nye save the world
yep I'm streaming now on netflix and
writing she's right at residuals money
that $12 to sensitive but you you're a
writer's assistant you were great we
headed off for a bunch of had a rocky
start but oh wait I'm out I don't mean
to do this but I gotta know what the
debate about Nicki Minaj we can talk
about it isn't that we just started
talking about monster yeah okay and
Katie says the best version of months I
agree and I disagree
who do you think happy she does because
okay he insults Kanye on that song on
his on his I gotta go back and listen
yes he insults Kanye on that verse and I
was like it was already falling out well
they've always had I mean yeah remember
when Kanye did the Big Brother song yeah
that was a Moche was mad about Jay
taking his friendship with Chris Martin
you fight over Chris that's how we
should have known likes to dress I like
this you know emo white dude before you
did you think he was like I like Jay
he's always just like okay and but I
love that verse because he
salt Kayne which in hello Kanye I've
always loved Kanye I will always love
Kanye but support that man he okay he's
doing great okay to say he was doing
fine fine yeah so our conversation was
where I remember we were sitting offices
at the table yet so we were talking
about Kanye and then we start talking
about monster and then she and I got
into got into it we got into it and then
what was funny was I remember being like
let's not talk about this cuz this is
gonna get 10th and then I remember I
texted people I knew from LA and I was
like there's this one Marcela I work
with and I'm either gonna hate her we're
gonna make good friends but it's gonna
go
[Music]
actually you know what that's a great
jumping point for my first question is
dating women comedians should you do
should you do it should you not do it
what's it like your you have a boyfriend
idea of a boy for her great mouth shut
he's balding he's my boyfriend and
that's probably why you don't want to
date a lady comedian cuz then she just
had come on her web series and say he's
short he's bought I'm fired for it
that's it this show yeah I will talk
about your dick on stage yes terrible
but I will but it only feels good you
know people stood on what their good
dick talked about yeah that's true too
they you know they can this a bad move
for me I can't be advertising how good
my man's dick is that showed you know so
we got a clash alarm detail I mean you
want to give a man too much confidence I
say make all the jokes negative I I was
dating a dude shorter than me and it was
like a big thing for me really five nine
I'll do showed I'm I'm not more seven so
I'd love to hear this story
my whole life is a in short is my whole
life is avoiding shorties try to
impregnate me that's my whole life
trying to fix their lineage no thank you
we try to fire Marcella and breed like I
try to climb any and ride this first
shelter crazy my five seven eight did
call myself beautiful three times so we
went to dinner
her father's a true man they love me me
I'm sure short dudes love you too
God is a good height for a woman yeah I
wanna dudes it's it's not too tall that
short men don't try it right right but
it's not like short men try with your hi
girl
they don't try with shower girls I have
slash
ya know I'll be like in a place and
it'll be like 2 inches top Molina I'm
411 and I'll be in her place and like a
man who's 5 feet will look at me and be
like really [ __ ] you guys meet eyes down
here you're sure I'm sure
like hell thank you I see that guy's the
same thing looks at me he's like you're
tall I'm sure it's that short man energy
of trying to prove that he's that he can
lift a tree or kochiya how's that so
chena has the tiny she like big man
would she wouldn't like she said the
German Shepherd she's intense
not to I mean this is me well you're a
lady comedian so we're back on topic you
know dating a short dude how was it um
how short he was um fun I think it was
like five seven oh five six maybe that's
tall in my family I shorts do I [ __ ]
his five seven I said yeah yeah I think
he was about that but he was very
well-educated so I would tell myself
he's very tall when he stands on his
degree justification women will die
anyway it was like absurdly good-looking
oh we're proud of myself for that one
day jobs
yeah um cuz I used to work as a bank
assistant bank manager I remember like a
few years in I was like starting to get
paid to do comedy and once you start
getting painted do comedy cuz like
there's a freedom there like I love
doing crowd workout talking [ __ ] and so
I would let it talk it shy watch but you
are a good [ __ ] talker online and in
person is very impressive
so I remember morning after a [ __ ]
great show I'm saying they're dealing
with the heckler like ripping a [ __ ] to
shreds the crowd is loving it I'm
feeling great about talking [ __ ] and
paid and the next day I go into work and
I have to be like yeah
help you and like they've talked you
know they talked down they take
advantage and you gotta sit there I mean
I'm sure as a stripper you be like
[ __ ] about the [ __ ] if you if you
have it in you
yeah I don't I worked I did data entry
for grandpa entering many is very
exciting and my boss at the job called
me Amy like and I could not convince him
that my name was Katie so one time is
all the same to him but I worked there
for six months and he was thirty two
older tamiya that's crazy
no young man so few hours late to a
four-hour shift once because I was never
gonna get in trouble like a buncha guys
I have been like I've done data entry
lots of temporary exciting tutor
stripper like all kinds of [ __ ] I work
to add a cheese shop once and a woman
was rude to me she told me I was an
idiot cuz the blue cheese I was cutting
kept crumbling which is you know like
learn your cheese man learn your cheese
and you just said to her excuse me I
have to go to the restroom
and then just left no just went away oh
wow and I left what else to deal with
this I would not be good in any sort of
situation handled
I cried in the walk-in yeah of course
not not good close academic Fame I love
to cry at work like I feel like um I
know I've been a waitress really like
I've you know served drinks like
cocktails stuff like shot girl I've been
shot girly boys and stuff but penis ship
is very similar to being a waitress
because or at least customer service
customer service and I hate it
there's a lot of people who tell you
that stripping is empowering and all
that Eden empowerment I didn't feel good
they powered you a deep I would you
girls like like more than comedy very
more than nothing has debased me
personally there's not a judgment or sex
workers I want
be clear listen don't call me a cut in
my DMS you guys do that sometimes
I mean par for the course come when I
was 12 I was like okay all right you're
not wrong make sense I see I see what
you're saying dad but um it was like it
was hard like I think one of the most
humiliating moment of my life was when I
like gave so they tell you this this is
my bad they tell you get the money up
front for a lap dance yeah I didn't like
it cuz I don't like to be pushy that's
also why I was the best Ripper
cuz I'm not a good saleswoman at all
can't sell [ __ ] not myself I'm not a
fantasy a finger mean I think it's a
goddamn thing so you know they tell you
not to not to get the dance before you
get the money
mmm so some man I give him a lap dance
and I will say I was bad at everything
about stripping except a lap dance that
was one thing I was decent at I believe
it uh you know so I give him a good lap
dance oh boy does not give me my money
yeah you know what he does he takes he
stacks four quarters together and shoves
it oh my god oh god the most humiliated
I've ever been in my entire life
oh my god well I will never forget that
man I will never forget that moment
Wow so there's a lot of I have anxiety
issues I got you know all kinds of
nervousness and when you're calm accused
I feel like stand-up made me more
introverted because if I'm the only one
talking and I'm back here y'all over
there I've gotten less accustomed to
being around people but if there was
anything that told me I never wanted to
deal with the public in a real way it
was that moment right there
so we got a lot of questions from
followers submitting whatever they want
life love work whatever related
questions if you want to submit a
question send them to you welcome
questions at gmail.com and will happily
answer them so the first question for
you ladies is how do you balance your
thriving career with family friends and
a love life is a love life and
afterthought at this point Wow I thought
this was like she liked this question
just drag me love life I guess I know
but I mean I think but I think that's
the I think that you're both right
though is that it is hard to do all of
the things that I think maybe people
think that it's easy for me because of
social media but it's more like I try to
make the time for things when I can but
I don't have a love life and thriving
career I mean I feel like our careers
are always like enough [ __ ] they're
hanging up and flow so sometimes I'm
hella broke sometimes I'm balling right
bad anxiety is always there yeah yeah I
don't know if you guys saw that um that
roundtable with The Hollywood Reporter
with all the like women and comedy and
it had like natasha Lyonne Alex
Bornstein Tiffany Haddish
it was really great and a Jane Fonda was
also in that table and it was [ __ ]
crazy to hear her say how she's always
worried about her next gig like it's
[ __ ] Jane Fonda you and she was born
into that one badly Wow she like anxious
chasing so I think that is it rest -
yeah no I think that's what really what
it is I think that when people when if
you admire someone you just assume that
they got their [ __ ] together that
everything looks great especially on
social media yeah but I think the
reality is that everyone has this [ __ ]
that they keep to themselves whether
they're struggling or not you do have
this [ __ ] that you want to keep to
yourself so I mean how to balance
everything it's hard I'm [ __ ]
stressed out right now Mitch
I'm [ __ ] tired right now I'm cold
right now I think it's easier to do one
or the other it's like if I'm like doing
work it's so easy to get really invested
in the job
yeah but then also it's hard to leave my
apartment because I am in hashtag love
yeah I was I was reading the article um
Rihanna just came out with an article I
see thank you yes it's an ID check it
out it's the dope article I'm Sarah
Paulson interviews her they have a
really interesting conversation but
Rihanna yes someone who's very busy
she's now taking personal days she puts
the letter P in her calendar to like so
that everyone knows that she's taking a
personal day [ __ ] in a different color
so that you can't not see yeah yeah and
so she's kind of prioritizing her own
self-care if you will because I think
that it's it's a matter of effort mm-hmm
I think that the key to it is effort yes
she chose to love her man yeah and it
was like it was really well to see that
like she was like I I want to love this
person yeah and I'm gonna make time to
love this person yeah you know I often
don't think of love that like
intellectually and just deliberate right
right to be like this is a good man I
want to invest I usually just like you
know let it happen
and so to see someone like her have to
you know sort of make it part of her job
is very fascinating to see because I'm
in a place where I am the most
fulfilling I've ever been professionally
but probably the one and part of the
lowest I've ever been personally right
trying to figure out who I am what I'm
doing in this town or whatever and to
see that too you have to give up
everything to chase that success and
then decide choose beautiful person is
wild a hard lesson to learn in real time
right these questions are all directed
at me just want to say that I don't know
personal business but it seems like you
are happily single for creatives do you
think singlehood gives you an edge do
you ever feel like being in a
relationship even with someone super
supportive and proud and independent
would prevent you from being as powerful
in your work that's interesting actually
that's a good Beyonce jay-z I always
think about them in terms of to create
owes being together and supporting
each other and how it can actually
elevate your career so I think that both
sides are true I mean I pointed at you
because you enjoy yeah I do have a
supportive boyfriend yeah I'm very
supportive he's very supportive and I
think like if you have a truly
supportive partner as opposed to someone
like I've had tons I love to date I love
to have a boyfriend boyfriends but like
a lot of them were like oh yeah it's
cool that you do comedy but they did not
mean it
yeah but Matt really means that yeah and
it's it's been a hard couple of years
moving from the place where I felt so
comfortable and moving from Chicago to
New York and the New York to LA and
without Matt I don't think I would have
been able to do those things because it
was nice to have someone who really
truly was so supportive yeah in my
corner yeah but at the same time when I
was single I wrote a lot of jokes all
the time as I was dating and sleeping
with weird men yeah but also I mean and
also not dating I mean for me it's I'm I
have no one to answer to I have no no
one to make time for because it's going
back to a Brianna said about she's
making this effort but that's kind of
the beauty and not dating is that you
don't have this extra effort to make on
someone or worry about what you're
talking about on stage if you want to
talk about them there was there was a
moment maybe like last week so I'm newly
like in this self-discovery mode I
finally let myself believe astrology
because I read a paragraph and I was
like holy [ __ ] that's me but so in my
whole life I've just chased boys that
weren't good for me I'm free like I said
chase men that will be terrible to me
and I know they're gonna be terrible to
me from instant
like minute one instantly but I sort of
just let I guess emotions take over and
what I realized is that I am too I like
to be untethered but I don't want like
I'm too selfish to admit that that's my
choice I say boys left me I talk about
it yeah yeah I work like I work my
selfishness and greediness in a passive
voice right and the
using poorly and passively what romantic
partners allows me to continue to share
sure that way yeah I can't imagine
choosing to love somebody and trying to
provide a stable relationship with
somebody when my whole life my career
everything I'm chasing is unstable so
and I can't imagine trusting anybody
enough to get to the part where they
could be a stable supportive partner if
you like you moved to three cities in
the last couple years
Yeah right imagine I would leave a man
behind him every city I when I was
living in Chicago I always planned on
leaving Chicago and I deliberately chose
partners who I was like I will dump you
in a minute and then I did and then when
I moved to New York I really I met Matt
and I really fell in love with him I
know but I expected him to be like SIA
this is like too unstable and especially
like here living in LA this is the first
time where I haven't like pursued a real
full-time office job and like I'm trying
to get this thing going for myself and
it it does I feel pressure because I
can't heat can never be the financially
unstable and I ever that's me that's I
am always the financially unstable one I
feel really bad about it and he keeps
telling me it doesn't matter to him and
I have to just trust that that's true
yeah I mean he travelled across the
country with me left a city he loves to
lay with me ever want that because I
wouldn't want the pressure of your good
time well I
I felt that way too but then I was like
you're being your own choices you have
to like take yourself out of that
equation because the if you really
respect and trust your partner they are
an adult who's also making their own
decisions sure um last question uh this
is way more lighthearted
why is picking a place to eat such a
pain in the ass Oh cuz people are
annoying there's a lady's - yeah but I
think conversation where it's like y'all
have that conversation I don't do
everything every day what do you eat
really I just eat Italian food like
everything oh I like I argue I could
have spaghetti like every night no no
I'm an issue
yes we're plain and boring people I
could like on God like it's always
Italian and Mexican there's no
complications there I have a restaurant
I like that's fancy for oh my god
cuisines and or a cheap one and they say
yeah that's crazy [ __ ] Oh wasting the
time like that I don't waste my time
doing it for two people when I'm hanging
up people it's always a question real
friends ring we have friends so we have
to have these cumbersome very important
water the car you gotta talk to other
people yeah I like to going with a plan
this is where we're going here this is
what we're doing I hate when you get in
a group of people in their language yeah
I'm gonna have food allergies to those
narrow down a lot yeah my boyfriend's
negan's that helps Nair
oh yeah he's vegan okay way so what's
that like veganism no you man be a vegan
oh not regular I I mean she adapts she
loves him right wasn't so much - Oh see
my basic [ __ ] of me is like I don't
want a man who don't eat meat I like it
he's like so much he's a better person
than me in every way I like that yeah
that's like if if I if I got in a car
accident and went brain-dead he'd keep
me alive in that coma forever I'm gonna
be by your side I would be pulling that
plug that's more [ __ ] my dude yeah
he'll be like to me if you murdered
someone we can work through nights
really you're a lunatic the only vegan I
think I would really seriously pay him
he don't want me is Andre 3000 oh my god
well that wraps the show you welcome
[ __ ] just want to say thank you to race
Ani and Katie McVeigh follow them and
everything they do online thank you so
much for tuning in see you next time
peace